hey screen junkies we're back with
another roast and this time we're
tackling walking dead that's right it's
the roast of Rick Grimes I want to share
with you one of our favorite sets enjoy
my name is Carol my cardigans are crisp
my casseroles are hearty and I've got
the biggest [ __ ] dick of anybody on
this goddamn stage thank you negan you
want us to bow to the saviors here's a
better idea you get on your knees and
suck my hot throbbing old lady boner ha
ha ha don't get it twisted I know I look
like somebody you'd see on Food Network
at 2:00 a.m. but I've killed more
suburban housewives than botched plastic
surgery that's true oh that's true
people think Daryl's such a badass
you'd be tough too if you knew that the
writers couldn't kill you off right AMC
makes most of their budget from selling
Daryl t-shirts to fat sad 30 year old
women who live with their grandparents
I'm the real badass right Kirkman killed
my ass in issue number 42 and I'm still
hanging around like AIDS and Glenn you
know the fans think Daryl and I are
gonna hook up right not gonna happen if
my only sexual option is banging the
human version of a can of skull
I'd rather scissor a log it's us and now
for sentence more terrifying than
watching a loved one get eaten by a pack
of walkers give it up for a Chris
Hardwick impersonator everyone or as I
like to call it a Ryan Seacrest
impersonator impersonator my faith
survived a walker apocalypse but after
seeing Chris Hardwick get a career I'm
convinced there is no God
Christian shows up without permission to
annoy America every day you're the
Microsoft Clippy of TV show hooks the
only thing I want to see you hosts is
the Walker virus
you show up at the end of things I love
and ruined the whole experience you're
the human equivalent of porn that cuts
to the guy's face during the money shot
oh what an old lady shouldn't watch porn
[ __ ] you you don't know my life I'm
Carol speaking of moderately attractive
white dudes who compensate for their
lack of a soul with a well tailored suit
Don Draper's here everybody Don thanks
for taking time from your busy schedule
of selling cigarettes to children to be
here Don taught a whole generation of
men that it's cool to be a misogynistic
alcoholic but he forgot to mention that
[ __ ] only works if you look like Jon
Hamm twist yeah easy
Shane and Laurie are here we know
Shane's a great guy the kind of guy
who'll give you the shirt off his back
because he likes to be naked when he
[ __ ] your wife Shane you stole your
lover from your best friend and your
face from everybody who's ever worked at
a hookah bar
and Laurie you hussy Laurie snatch gets
beaten up so much she started calling it
season one Carol run because it's true
yeah ma easy there Carl
nobody likes you Carl let's be real you
greasy little one-eyed [ __ ]
but enough about your dick Carl looks
like Teddy Ruxpin come to life and then
got really into Nickelback Oh too harsh
you thought I was gonna go easy on a kid
I've killed little girls with more nuts
than Carl lest we forget
quit crying and look at the flowers
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] Carol thank you but
we're all here for you Rick Rick you
power-hungry [ __ ] Rick's told so many
women know they made him a judge in
Texas
I've had enough of your [ __ ] I want
to lead the group and I seem to be the
only one here who actually watches AMC
because this isn't Breaking Bad Rick
people are getting eaten we don't have
five seasons to wait around for you to
grow a dick and handle your [ __ ] by the
time you finish your slow burn arc from
southern sheriff to apocalypse survival
warlord we're all going to be deader
than low winter Sun do you guys remember
low winter Sun I didn't [ __ ] think so
we need somebody in charge who can act
fast
who's not afraid to get their hands
dirty I'm not here to cuddle I'm here to
cut a [ __ ]
even if said [ __ ] is only maybe sort of
possibly sick or in a loving
relationship or 12 years old and then
after I cut that [ __ ]
I'm gonna use that same knife to cut
everyone a nice big slice of warm apple
pie Carol out you thought Rick Grimes
had been through hell you ain't seen
nothing yet
I don't know what was harder for Rick
watching Lori take her last breath or
the fact that it smelled like Shane's
Karl Karl where's Karl I'm up dad
cowboy pirate cop choose one like I
trying to be all the Village People at
once
screen junkies presents the roast of
Rick Grimes watch now exclusively on
screen junkies plus Rick you failed more
black people than FEMA
[Music]
holy [ __ ] Carol killed it she really did
Julie Prescott for the win so many other
amazing people were there doing a
roaster Rick and you can see it all if
you click here and register for free
over at screen junkies plus or if you
want to be in the audience for a taping
of a future roast click this other box
come hang out with us watch us make fun
of people you just got to be in the area
and maybe you'll come check it out also
tell us what roasts you want to see next
since you guys are watching these we
want to do a ton more you can comment
down below and tell us which roast you
should want to see us do and hopefully
maybe you'll catch it yeah be awesome
also we were pointing at the comments
not our dicks yeah that would have been
gross
I was pawneeans dick